can I get my friends to eat lunch with
me by drumming like a wasp hi I'm Tim
and this is science the show where we
ask science questions and the answer is
always yes today we're talking about
wasps not that kind of wasp guys this is
Chris
he's the correct kind of wuss he's also
my assistant for today's experiment
don't mistake me for no bee mother I'm a
wasp wasps much like you and I are very
social creatures they communicate they
engage they slide into each other's DMS
and sometimes they invite each other
over for dinner
dr. Benjamin Taylor at LaGuardia
Community College found that wasps
rhythmically drum their abdomens against
their nests to inform each other when
there's food nearby
it's called gastric drumming and it
works for wasps why can't it work for me
yesterday I couldn't get anyone to eat
lunch with me but that's all going to
change with an experiment I like to call
humans is wasps - the plan is order
three large pizzas at 12:30 p.m. when
the pizzas arrive I start drumming on my
cubicle with these drumsticks that I
caught at a Sonic Youth Show in 1999 if
my theorem is correct my co-workers will
follow the sound to my cubicle and
consume the pizza with me for nutrients
and friendship the pizza's here
great thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
guys guys guys um I think we have to
fire Tim he really thinks he's a
scientist
I guess I'm gonna have to eat all this
pizza myself wait Chris you came of
course I did I'm the only one your
vitami a blast
if you want to make friends you should
treat them like people not wise huh
maybe I'll try that next time
looks like we did learn something after
all until next time I'm Tim and this has
been science
[Music]